- All right, everybody,
let's finish up with something
fun from social media.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
So, last week marked the end
of Hispanic Heritage Month.
Our new season hadn't premiered quite yet,
so let's keep that celebration going
with an eight-year-old boy recently named
the world's youngest mariachi singer
in "The Guinness Book of Records."
This is Mateo.
(audience awing)
Oh, he's so cute.
He's been performing Mariachi
worldwide since he was four
and he's just getting started, everybody.
We have Mateo watching
on WOAI San Antonio.
What's up?
(audience cheering)
- Kelly, how are you?
- I am so good.
I love having a fellow Texan
on the show always, Mateo.
So, how did you get started in mariachi?
- I kept following my sister
because I always went to her
performances and all her stuff.
And then one day I really
listened to the music
and I really loved the
music when I listened to it.
Also, this is a traje de charro.
It is one of our most important suits
in the Mexican culture.
- Yeah, it's iconic, yeah.
So, do you think you
wanna do this forever?
Is this like a thing you wanna do,
like sing for the rest of your life?
- Yes, I wanna sing
for the rest of my life
and I'm really having fun
and I also want to sing all over the world
and be the best mariachi ever.
- Yeah.
(audience cheering)
Oh my God.
Mateo, I'm gonna fly you here myself
and we're gonna sing together.
You wanna do that with me?
- Yes, please.
- I will sing in Spanish.
I will sing in Spanish with you, Mateo,
I love you so much.
I more than like you.
I'm loving you right now, oh my gosh.
That's not all though, Mateo,
I wanna tell you our season
long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go-to pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like you, sir.
So they're gonna give you $1,000.
How's that sound, Mateo?
- Thank you so much.
(audience cheering)
- Oh my gosh, I love you so much, Mateo.
You made me so happy.
Thank you to all our guests today,
Arnold Schwarzenegger,
Elmo, Oscar the Grouch,
Laura Cerand and Hypen,
and all our friends at 30
Rock and the NBC Page Program
and of course, the legendary Paul Shaffer.
(audience cheering)
Y'all have a great day and if
it's not, try and change it.